[Music]
good afternoon how can dr d
and i help good afternoon how are y'all
gentlemen doing
doing good man about yourself doing
pretty good um
i got a question i've been dating this
woman for since
mid-april and we have
i've tried to move our relationship
further along and
you know started getting into finances
and asking about how
she's financing in budgeting and i just
recently got on
the dave ramsey clan uh about september
and i was
i've been able to pay off like thirty
five hundred dollars in like two
three weeks so congrats and
yeah thanks and you know and
i've tried to get her income up and
every time i mention
she's a stay-at-home mom and every time
i mention that you know
she needs to try and get her income up
she gets mad at me
for mentioning you know that she needs
maybe trying to go back to work and get
her income up
is she a single mom yes she's a single
mom
with three kids okay and how old are you
i'm 28 28 okay how old is she yeah
she's 29. okay so she she
and living off alimony essentially well
she's living off child support
right basically child support and she's
only getting like 800
something dollars sure and you know i
tried to tell her she needed to get
her income up or you know she's gonna
either
move out of the house she's in and sell
her car or try to get her income
up because she's never gonna make ends
meet
listen brother ben i'm telling you this
because i love you
and you're our fellow tennessean okay
the last thing on planet earth a single
mom with three kids
needs is a boyfriend of about four or
five or six months
telling her what she needs to be doing
with her life
what she needs to be selling no hold on
hold on what she needs to be selling
what she needs to be doing brother
that's way way out of bounds way out of
anything that makes any sort of sense
even if you think you've got the math
part figured out
hearing that sets off every alarm she's
got
okay and so the best thing you can do
right now
is model your own actions and your own
thoughts
you can live towards the dave ramsey
you're still single you can be taking
care of you
in this process and as you all continue
to date you met her in the middle of a
pandemic
so i'm just telling you things are going
to be different over the next year or so
as you are making your way through this
relationship further the thing that she
needs
less from you is advice and the things
she needs more from you
is a relationship is you okay
so talking about hey here's some things
that i'm doing in my life
here are some accomplishments here's
some some um
goals i'm setting and working towards
working forward
but man stay out of that hey here's what
you
should be doing here's what you need to
be selling you need to get off the couch
and start working some more
brother that's some dangerous dangerous
west coast
on fire territory mean i mean that's
what i've been you know i've been
modeling for
you know and and telling her this is
where i'm going you know this is where
i'm at
and she's you know she's slowly seeing
where i'm coming from
it's just it's just trying to get her to
you know go with it you know go with the
flow and
and try to get her income up to where
she because i know she's struggling
because she's told me a number of times
that she struggles
a lot no question hey y'all been dating
for how long again been
since april since april of this year so
it's about what six seven months four
months four months four months
okay all right so check this out man i'm
gonna say something again on the day of
ram to show that some people may not
like uh dating the root word for dating
is data and so when you're dating
someone
you're gathering data to see if you want
to proceed forward with that individual
if this young lady after four months is
showing you that in this season of my
life i do not want to do this
that is data for you now to be like all
right do i want to
live with this or not live with this and
so if you do not want to live with it
then move on
if you do then it goes back to what
you're saying be in a relationship with
her
and do not try telling her about herself
right
and and ben did the classic
yeah which is i i'm telling you ben
this is what i've been doing for 20
years
and ben's response is i know man but
listen but listen
this is where like i know but i'm
different like this is the right way
trust me ben for 30 days brother i want
you to not give her one piece of advice
that relationship it's october 2
november 2.
you've got our number call us i want you
to go 30 days no advice
no advice i want you to say call her in
the morning and say i hope you're having
a great day
yes anything i can do to serve you today
can i love you today yes
and then in the evening time if you
don't know don't skip to the evening
text here at lunch time how's your day
going that's right
come on you know what i'm saying text
her some song lyrics
yes yes whatever it needs to do
in the evening i hope today was awesome
i love you
bye listen and i'll see you tomorrow and
no advice yes
no if she calls and says hey yo what
should i do i want your answer to be
you're brilliant you grew three children
in your body come on man what do you
think you should do well yes
what do you think and whatever you do
decide to do i'm gonna support
that 30 days 30 days
and call us back don't call dave ramsey
back no wait till you see dr d and
anthony o'neil on the show
and give us a call back and i guarantee
you i guarantee you
that y'all's relationship would be much
better and if it's not
let's be real then you need to make the
decision with that data
to either move forward or to stay right